[Music]
good to see you look as fantastic as you
always do I mean yes fancy you have a
good point I do look fantastic
thank you you're ready I mean in this
house exactly a celebrity how I am
bringing it to Celebrity Big Brother
yeah you are I have no question with
that let's rewind I want up from the
beginning are you a fan of the show how
did this come about
how'd you get involved well yeah I have
been watching since season one in fact
if you go back and watch the finale of
season 1 they did it outside and there
was an audience oh no I'm in that
audience you can see my head oh yeah
you're you're you so you're hardcore
hardcore alright so that that means it
that's an advantage or is that not an
advantage like sometimes people coming
in that don't know a lot don't don't
overthink strategies and alliances what
do you think being a fan is a total
advantage I've been watching the show
since the beginning and I've always said
Ross you would do great nothing because
I've gone I can't I promise you I have
the strategy I have the gameplay you
know the physical part is gonna be a
challenge for me I'm not gonna like hang
from a bar for 18 hours and win a
challenge so I'm gonna have to make up
for that with my game play okay but I'm
ready all right are you are you ready to
say goodbye to things like cell phones
connection to the outside world yeah I
know she don't wearing a watch I know I
have no idea what time it is right now
is it's screwing with my head
listen I am a pop culture fanatic right
I get off on refreshing and knowing
what's going on in the world and it's
been you know like over a day now I have
no idea is Trump still president I don't
know okay no idea who won the Grammys I
can't answer do you know to see how it
kills me not to know who won the Grammy
I have to just stay in your pain I know
I am no help to you and I have a month
to go because did you know I'm gonna win
big brother so I would go in the house
the whole time
alright that's so why are you gonna win
why are you gonna take this well I think
people underestimate me because you know
I'm kind and I'm sweet but but no I'd be
truly you know I'm always nice but very
kind and sweet thank you very much they
may underestimate me and I hope they do
you know like underestimate me all the
way to the finale so I think it's fair
to say that because of your knowledge of
Big Brother
you know your your competitive guy
clearly and you're not afraid to make
alliances and kind of go out other
celebrities I mean that's part of it yes
I'm not gonna commit to making alliances
until I see who's in the house the good
day a house full of wackadoodles and
then then it's all every man for himself
okay
I'll be solo flying solo at that point
you have to take it seriously because
when you make an alliance it's like a
relationship you know and so you sort of
tethered to that person throughout and
if they are not good at the game then
you're screwed
are you in a relationship in real life
yeah almost almost 10 years with my
partner Salvador okay great so then
those show manses all arias never got to
show man Big Brother watch out ladies
[Laughter]
the funny story to tell after Big
Brother so what are your biggest fears I
mean you seem like a guy I mean I know
you're a guy who's used to the cameras
around but not every round every minute
of every day you'd be watching yourself
where you were your biggest worries
about this I mean that part doesn't
really scare me maybe it's because I've
done so much live TV or something and I
really am like this 24/7 so I've got
nothing to hide there's nothing I'm you
know veiled from from the audience my
one concerns well everyone's concerns
would be is bathroom and shower you know
like I don't want people America you
don't you know soon so I am I've been
assured that you're gonna I've been
assured that you're gonna be spared that
okay but they have been speaking that
they have revealed some aspects of that
some changes to the house that they've
made you've probably seen things like
you all get your own bed I know there's
a square table now sort of out did you
notice the espresso machine in the
kitchen things like listen I mean the
square table instead of around was a
genius move I'm glad somebody hired a
decorator before I got in that house it
looks great
yeah actually I saw some pictures online
before it was announced I thought oh hey
I live there or what about the food
situation you know I cook every day and
so I plan on cooking and if there's a
chef a slippery chef in the house I plan
on eating maybe pick up some tips but
the one thing I'm concerned about is you
know I'm not a negative person
I cut toxic people out of my life and
confrontation is not something I look
forward to so if there's a lot of that
in the house I'll have to figure out how
to deal with it how to manage that mom
what a character we're about a persona I
mean as a fan of the show you understand
that sometimes people are playing
characters they're there in the planet
part in many ways is that something that
you plan on doing are you doing any more
just like yourself well you know in the
real world you know you can trust me you
know I always keep my word but inside
the house I I don't know that I would
trust me you know I have a goal I have a
goal of winner Celebrity Big Brother and
I don't want to hurt anybody's feelings
you know I will love you but I will hug
you straight out the door that's listen
you gotta do what you gotta do I want to
win obviously you're busy gal you do a
lot of different things in this in this
position the entertainment business
oftentimes career opportunities open up
for the four people that do reality
shows like this so is that something
that you look what opportunities would
you like to see come you know well
listen I think the audience gets to see
me
I think the audience in my career has
seen me in little snippets you know from
Leno to Chelsea or drag race just giving
a little joke here and there on the red
carpet interviewing somebody I'm excited
for people to get to see me just being
comfortable and casual and having
conversations you know I have a lot of
strong opinions not just about pop
culture about about politics I have a
lot of personal things going on in my
life now that I think a lot of people
can relate to SiC family members
struggles and so I would love to to open
that part of myself up to the audience
you know just to show that like I may
have this voice and I may be a little
animated but I really am just like them
there's been some buzz about different
possibilities of celebrities in this
what's the name of celebrity that you
would love like who would you love to be
in the house with I mean Oprah she's
gonna be and I just a student I just so
much going on we I planned that she and
I would probably be roommates you know I
mean I'd like braid her hair
I see that that's that's your fantasy
honey sound a playoff yeah well pretty
pretty sure that's what's gonna be like
somebody that you like you really hope
it's not gonna bounce rather yeah I mean
anybody that would bring a necessary
negative drama
I want morosa there are certain people I
don't want to be there you know what I
mean
like that type that's it it's a de type
that just can't you just can't help but
be negative I just
god bless them but it would be a real
pain in my ass if they were there so you
know you talk a little negative people
be in the house what happens what's your
strategy of dealing with that negativity
with that non-stop sort of barrage of
negative you know I I don't plan on
engaging in like an argument or a
screaming match but if somebody were to
come at me I would go ahead and educate
them oh yeah you just have to stand up
for yourself
I've been doing that my whole life I
grew up in a farm town like this you
know so I listen I'm kind but if
somebody comes at me I got to let them
know that's not okay what you do like
how far will you go to win this I plan
on being able to keep them keep my
integrity okay to be kind throughout and
be proud of how I played at the end but
I plan on winning as well so right I
know I'm in for I'm in for quite a jar
it's gonna be quite the year the belt
yeah mm-hmm yeah yeah wish me luck